non moi il ya une chose qui m'étonne
c'est que on vient de voir jeanne mas et
téléphone jalma je crois qu'elle a eu
deux victoires de la musique téléphone 1
et puis on parle toujours de la chanson
française comme si elle allait mourir
comme des baleines bleues ou pis des
bébés phoques
qu'est ce que tu en penses tu auras nous
la chanson française va pas si mal que
ça quand même pas trop mal non faussée
pour un je vous prends pas non plus à
léonie au relais avec les looney way est
complètement contradiction je sers avec
il ya un problème au niveau des fm je
trouve qu'ils diffusent peut-être moins
un petit peu trop de musique anglo
american cela dit en général c'est de la
bonne musique et quand les français font
de la bonne musique ou la bonne chanson
jai ils n'ont pas de problèmes de
diffusion probable sainte foy et
concernées pour les ventes de liste tout
à fait je vois était un problème de
qualité chanson française oui mais le de
difficultés à s'exprimer
jean s'est pour sa part me semblait même
quand c'est mauvais mais voilà